you tell him how we met you're really
good at telling we met at a singles
group we were looking for each other the
first money of the whole collection is a
Valentine's Bunny about this big it's
really cute it says this is guess how
much I love you I went I went to a
florist shop to get her a gift and
everything was bears and bears and bears
and a couple turtles and a couple ducks
and I'm a contrary and I'd like to do
things that are different calling in my
honey-bunny
he liked that and I found a bunny in a
giant balloon and then she gave me one
and so we started going on their first
Easter the first Easter and then it
became every holiday we give each other
but again I couldn't wait so I would get
her a bunch of them and she'd say wait
till the holiday and I'd say no I gotta
go and so we started eventually it
became everyday all our wedding gifts a
lot most of the wedding gifts for
bunnies bye bye our wedding people knew
we were collecting bunnies and so became
a big thing and then I made the wedding
cake it was a carrot cake those stairs
going up to the cake there was a bride
and groom when it was a bunny and
bunnies were a part of our life just
from the beginning and everyone kind of
knew that and they'd write cards to the
honey bunnies and that kind of stuff
so we we're collecting about four years
and then we decided to open up to the
public because we would joke that we
lived in a bunny Museum and her family
and friends would joke and say it's too
bad other people can't see these
fantastic things you have so we opened
up to the public and that was 20 years
ago
[Music]
we have over a hundred categories within
the museum and it's interesting you know
the saying
two's company three's a crowd for us
two's company three or more is a
category so some people will hop over
and they'll look at a shuffle ago I
don't get the category here but there's
no category it's a story of love between
Candace and I and what we want to bring
forth is a way of showing a couple's
love towards each other and how it
perpetuated the collection further we'll
further it's it's it's no different than
anything else wouldn't it comes to love
the fact is everyone should have the
same religion and religion means how you
live your life it does not mean being a
certain religion it's what what you
believe in whether you're a vegetarian
or whether you're a dog owner and you
you want to marry another dog owner
because someone else you have to have a
similarities to begin with so you have
the basis of similarity and then you do
something together some people might
like antiquing or traveling or they play
golf so that their goal is to go and
play all the golf courses around the
world you know but you know it's it's
something that you do together
[Music]
you